(electronic whooshing
and beeping)
- Come on, you gotta hit this.
- I don't know,
man, we're working.
- I'm never not
high at this job.
Come on, man, this
is how we roll.
Mort, tell him.
- Hey, he made do this
my first time, too.
Don't worry, I also hated it.
- [Driver] And now Mort
and I are best friends.
- [Mort] 'Cause he
made me get rid of
the rest of my friends.
- He had two friends,
both named Gary.
And they sucked.
- I loved the Garys.
- Why don't we just
deliver these pizzas?
- Are you the trainee
or am I the trainee?
I'm wearing the red shirt.
You're wearin' a
played-out white shirt
like a pussy.
- Okay,
let's take it easy, huh?
- Just hazing.
But seriously, man, Samuel
said I'm supposed to train you.
I'm the head delivery driver.
Red shirts are for closers.
- Isn't the deal closed
when they make the order?
- Just hit this, man!
- I don't want to, man.
- He's gonna be pretty shitty
to you until you
smoke that weed.
- Yeah.
(sighs)
- All right.
- Yeah!
- One hit.
- You're a party man.
(laughing)
Why's it look like this?
- It's a dick pipe, go.
Oh my God, wait,
that's the crack pipe.
- Oh fuck, spit it
out, spit it out!
- (laughing) Classic haze!
(laughing)
- Is it--
- It's just weed.
Take another one
because you got confused
during that one.
- Yeah, sorry about that.
- You want your brain
clear when you smoke.
Yeah! (laughing)
- Shotgun me, shotgun me.
- Don't do that, Mort.
That's for girls.
It's so gross.
- Oh hell yeah!
- All right ,give it to me.
- Hat trick, hat trick.
- Yeah, three-way boys out.
(dub step music)
- [Mort] Hey,
shouldn't one of us be
at the home base right now?
- Relax, Mort,
Samuel doesn't care.
And besides, what's
more important?
Getting customers their food,
or bonding with
your new teammate?
- Oh, I'm really high.
Too high!
I wanna call my mom.
What if my stepdad answers?
Fucking hate Bruce!
- No! That's why I emphasized
that as like the positive one.
Mort, you gotta be on
the same page as me, man.
- I am.
- No you're not.
Cause it confuses the trainee.
- The trainee's
already confused.
(distorted speech)
- No I didn't man.
- Guys, I haven't been this high
since I saw Avatar
in the theater.
(laughs)
- That movie sucked.
I'm psyched for
the sequel, though.
Let's do this.
(doorbell)
- Uh, Pie Guys delivery?
- This can't be my pizza.
- Why not?
- Cause I ordered my pizza
over a fucking hour ago,
that's why not.
- Um, I'm sorry ma'am. Man!
- Did you just call me ma'am?
- No!
- Are you stoned right now?
- No.
- Don't fucking lie
to me shit stain!
(yelling)
- What the fuck?
- Wait, wait, wait,
wait! I know you!
- No, no, no, no, you
don't know him, Mort.
Let's just do what
he says, okay?
- You're John's friend.
You picked him up from
work a week ago. That's it.
- Goddamn it, Mort.
You ruined it.
We were gonna X him.
- Like Jimmy
Kennedy experiments.
- Why was I supposed
to know, man?
- I was winking at you.
- You always wink.
- [Trainee] But
you do wink a lot.
- I don't always wink,
what are you talking about?
- Always winking.
- Do you know this guy?
- Yes, this is my buddy Steak.
He's an actor.
- Hey, what's up man?
Don't worry, this is
just a starter pistol.
- Oh, I recognize you.
You're the guy from
the carpet commercial.
- Oh, yeah, "Gentleman's carpet.
Always clean, never mean."
- That makes me always think,
like, are they implying
that people at other
carpet stores are mean?
- Oh yeah, I don't know the
business side of things.
I'm just the hired gun.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No pun intended.
(gunshot)
- Oh my god!
- Sorry!
- What the fuck?
- I got a big fat index
finger and accidentally
pulled the trigger.
(gunshot)
- Damn it! Can you
figure out the trigger?
- Dude, I'm sorry.
(crying)
- You okay? You okay?
Go get some ice. Go
get some ice, yes.
- Am I bleeding?
- No, you're not,
no you're not bleeding.
- Why are you winking?
Unbelievable!
- Shh, shh.
- Yeah, you guys were pretty
scared for a second, though.
- [Mort] It was more
confusing than it was scary.
- Hey.
Hey, guess where I've been?
Making deliveries because
all my drivers were gone.
- Relax, Samuel.
- I'm sorry. I'm cool.
I'm cool. It's just
been very busy.
- Well, instead
of yelling at us,
you should be congratulating
Rob, who, did a fantastic
job on his first delivery.
High five!
- What?
- Congratulations, Rob.
- Hey great work,
buddy, but be patient.
Mort had to shadow
me for two months
before he could fly solo.
- That's because you kept
telling Samuel I wasn't ready.
- Shhnah. Look, your training
is almost 25% complete.
Your next mission is two parts.
First part, I need you
to go to the supermarket
and pick up some drain cleaner.
The toilet kind.
Second part, go to my apartment.
I'll give you the
address, you're gonna want
to go into the bathroom.
- Here.
You're not a trainee anymore.
- Goddamn it, Samuel.
- Get in there, come on,
we're busy.
- Whoa, this shirt is way
too big and super filthy.
- Oh yeah, must've
been Steingold's shirt.
- Oh yeah, he had a heart
attack in the bathroom.
- Mhmm.
- He didn't die in
this shirt, did he?
- Questions are for trainees.
You're a driver now.
- Hey, this is your
life now, buddy. Wow!
(sighs)
(electronic music)